[Música]
É Isso Aí acabamos de fazer três
continentes em menos de 24 horas meu
Deus Olha isso aqui então bom galera eu
adoro viajar todo mundo sabe disso eu
acho que eu já conheci uns 80 países Eu
não tenho tanta certeza do número de
países porque eu já perdi uma mala em
viagem e eu perdi o passaporte com todos
os carinhas e eu sou apaixonado por
países que falam língua portuguesa então
muita vontade de conhecer todos e dessa
vez eu vim conhecer Cabo Verde Cabo
Verde é um país relativamente pequeno
tem aproximadamente umas 600 mil pessoas
espalhadas por 10 Ilhas diferentes e
vulcão tem praia bonita tem gente bonita
e tem muita coisa legal para você
conhecer vem comigo
brincadeira entra aqui vem conhecer
nosso apê em Cabo Verde com as roupinhas
do Hype Olha só como é que tá as roupas
do Leo ai como é que tá a cuequinha do
Lilo Olha como tá os pingentes do Leo
link na descrição se você quer ser minha
gente vem cá que eu vou mostrar para
vocês eu gosto muito de viajar e muita
gente gosta de saber como é né galera
gosta de saber e aí você vai para onde e
tal Hoje a gente vai conhecer mais um
país chamado Cabo Verde Olha que lugar
lindo todo mundo fala português o povo
me ama na rua me abraça mano Ah é muito
massa nem conhecer aqui ó
olha só que bonito
acho que lugar lindo tá apaixonado mano
a cozinha já é aqui É só virar aqui onde
a gente tem o nosso jantar íntimo né
Espero que a gente fabrica a nossa
comida
não sei porque foi ele que eu te passo
você não quer que a visita deixa o seu
banheiro fedendo vem aqui de ouro e tal
S armários de toalha de toalha ah sei lá
quero malhar e tal vem pra cá chega aqui
ó
se ligou Cabo Verde
[Música]
do mar que eu quero que vocês vejam que
eu quero que vocês veja
esse quarto hein
uma passada do homem [__] de um pole
dance aí não tinha visto
eu quero ficar aqui e ao mesmo tempo eu
quero ver quero ver o
banheirinho de ouro
[Música]
passou um tempo e o banheiro é de rico
quando tem dois chuveiros mano
matou em caiu
Agora que eu vi que tinha uns vacilei
e tal como vocês podem ver a viagem do
Brasil para Cabo Verde que primeiro a
gente vai para Lisboa depois para cá
muita retenção de líquidos
chegando no novo nível
de Rico a gente não sabe as coisas que
tá usando que é isso mano sério mesmo
tipo assim não
Vou ligar para o Neymar a gente queria
mostrar o peixe já que você já está
curtindo a viagem Tem várias coisas da
viagem para mostrar não esquece de
deixar o like aqui essa é uma forma da
gente dar uma movimentada eu sei que às
vezes vocês querem ver como que é o
lugar é só para matar a curiosidade não
é para se mostrar isso aqui o Hype é
participar disso tem que estar vestido
de raiva hein link na descrição é o Hype
ui cuequinha tem cuequinha também
não esquece de deixar o like e
acompanhar tudo que tá acontecendo aqui
pela gente em Cabo Verde é isso agora a
gente vai esperar o André Loureiro que
perdeu o voo
Então tá vindo de Lisboa agora 6 horas
vai chegar acho que não sei de meia
noite
[Música]
porque tem brincos e tem pingentes não
era games hein primeiro link da
descrição do vídeo tem um Hype você que
quer entrar para tropa do W aqui estamos
nós ó trajado de aproveitar aqui para
conhecer em Cabo Verde um pouquinho da
culinária